casse-tête du déconfinement ne fait que
commencer face à la montée de la
polémique
emmanuel macron fait marche arrière les
plus de 65 ans ne seront pas obligés de
rester confinée après le 11 mai avant la
conférence de presse commune prévue
demain avec edouard philippe et olivier
ferrand le chef de l'état l'assurent ils
ne souhaitent pas de discrimination
concernant lés seniors
il en appelle à la responsabilité
individuelle de chacun a indiqué hier
soir l'elysée
lors de son dernier discours il avait
pourtant demandé aux personnes les plus
vulnérables et aux personnes âgées de
rester même après le 11 mai confiné
réaction à bordeaux 70 ans est en forme
et on est encore très vague idée et on
peut rendre service c'est ça le problème
c'était il ya une majorité de personnes
de plus de 70 ans qui vont rendre
service on en a besoin des anciens et
ils en ont besoin les jeunes
voilà c'est pour ça que c'est important
d'y réfléchir je pense qu'on est tous
responsables et je pense à partir du
moment où on a des problèmes de santé on
doit effectivement resté confiné mais on
est suffisamment grand pour le
comprendre aux autres que c'est quand
même assez d'être discriminatoire parce
que là aujourd'hui
on n'a pas de retour sur
la contagion entre les seniors qui sont
entre guillemets validé qui ne sont pas
du tout malade est ce qu ont des grosses
aux pathologies et on nous met tous à la
même enseigne sachant qu'à 65 ans on
nous dit qu'on peut travailler plus
longtemps parce que on a une espérance
de vie est plus longue donc il ya un
discours qui est un petit peu on va dire
anachronique on a du mal à comprendre